- So I tell the story of the first time
I set up a play date for Sasha
because I just had to find a mother
that I thought I wanted to meet.
- I just love that
you're doing a play date.
- We set up a play date.
- I can't imagine that call.
- She is now a good friend of mine
but at first I just
saw her and I was like,
"Why don't you have
little Olivia come over?"
And of course she was like, "Sure."
And so later, as we became friends,
she told me the story of what it was like
coming to pick Olivia up after that,
coming to the White House.
What is on the other
side of being my friend?
Well, it is a social security check,
it's background check.
- Background check, all that.
- It's a clear vet before you
can even come in the gate.
- Oh my gosh.
- Not to mention she wasn't
even coming in the house
but she went and got her
hair done, her nails done,
washed her car.
- She was like, yeah!
- She was like, I'm not showing
up messy at the White House,
so she pulls in and I
decide outside of protocol
that I'm gonna take little
Olivia down to the south lawn.
Well, you do not leave the
residence as a principal
because it sets off all
this outside security.
The counter assault team goes into action.
- Oh my god.
- Black flack jackets
with machine guns, dogs.
They start descending.
So here I come, her car is
now surrounded by security.
I step out into the south
lawn with little Olivia
and I'm like, "Get out, come on out."
But she had been explicitly told
under no circumstances, ma'am,
are you to get out of your car.
- This woman is about to pee her pants.
- So I'm calling her, I'm like, "Get out."
And she's like, (groans)
(both laughing)
So she's slowly gets out carefully
and we have a great chat.
She played it all off, I
didn't know any of this,
so I'm retelling her story in the book.
- Oh, this is a nice woman.
- And she is now one of my best friends.
Olivia's like a daughter to me.
Lo and behold, the new daisy popped up
and it is a beautiful thing.
And if I hadn't taken
the risk to extend myself
and to reach out to a
stranger, and make a friend,
she wouldn't be in my life.
And so if I can make new
friends, anybody can, all right?
- 'Cause its painful, right?
(audience clapping)
(laughing) Oh my God!